the jurogan experience what did you
think about
when they attached in the coveted relief
bill 180 days for the cia to release all
the information they have about the ufos
[Laughter]
that's one of the things i love about
this is this yeah
oh my god yeah we can't be taken
seriously that way yeah no
no but i will say this i tell people
this all the time they say they say why
is it so what a day i said because he's
curious about everything he's
genuinely curious about everything and
that's that's a it's a good question
look i'm happy that
that uh when it comes to ufos there's a
lot of things that the agency needs to
keep
you know off the radar right for sources
and methods right
it's a need to know issue and frankly
again going back to
what's in in you know the us best
interest
you know for that day when china decides
to release all of their intel
operations and information then great
maybe it's time for us to be transparent
but
that's not the way that it is uh
secret programs defense
vehicles well know what i'm saying what
i'm saying is oh in terms of the ufo i
think
uh yeah a great portion of it is yeah
great portion of this is uh
is uh 50 oh
47 actually but don't tell anybody i
said that
that's well known um inside the
community
uh yeah no look i think it's good
because i think the
look it's for the same reason the
pentagon released the information about
atip about the advanced aeronautical
threat identification program i think i
think it's actually good
there's no reason why we shouldn't
unless
you are talking about developmental
aircraft as an example
right which is important because whether
you're talking about hypersonic aircraft
or missiles or whatever it is
there's some stuff that needs to be kept
off the off the radar screen
uh because there is a tremendous
competition going on right now for
particularly for things like control of
space that's that's going to be a huge
issue
right about because the weaponization of
space for a long time people are
thinking oh space it's a great
exploration and it's good for mankind
and frankly um you know there is a race
to figure out how to weaponize space
and so as an example of what we're
talking about the idea of of
just saying oh we're going to open the
books as a country
and reveal all our information about you
know developmental aircraft as an
example
that's the wrong move right because but
do you think
there are any credible stories whether
it's from commander david fravor
who saw that tic tac vehicle off the
coast of san diego
or whatever video yeah
if i had to point to one i would say
favor yeah i would say without a doubt
i'd say the one that if i were somebody
who's looking for some
redemption because i've been beating the
drum about ufos and nobody's ever
believed me they always roll their eyes
i would say the one thing that would
give them comfort would be the the
incident
with uh commander fravor and and that
uh sighting that's that's one
that i have yet to see an explanation
for that makes any sense
well not only that there was they
tracked it yeah
like there's oh yeah yeah and then also
it blocked
their uh radar systems which is an act
of war
and actively jammed radar systems it's
it's
it's not simple as like they saw
something they didn't know what it was
like they tracked this thing going from
i think it was close to 80 000 feet
above sea level to one
down yeah in one second yeah no signs of
propulsion yeah
uh no heat signatures nothing right and
it was just it was
a yeah it's it's one of those things you
look at and you go okay and look the
a-tip program made sense in the sense
that you know if
if uh a nation is out there if chinese
are out there or the russians or
whomever
and they're developing uh uh propulsion
capability that we have don't know about
then yeah we should have a mechanism uh
within the pentagon within the intel
community to understand what that is
let's let's research just let's
investigate right
and so oftentimes you know they come to
a logical conclusion
the fravor incident i have yet to see
any um
information that explains it right so
that to me
and and also as you pointed out the way
that it was uh tracked
the the verification of it from very
credible
uh you know individuals um that
to me is is like the the prime example
and they have video footage of this
thing too
and then on top of that camera footage
it's incredible yeah and the nimitz
saying that these things are
fairly common that they're seeing them
every couple of weeks they were seeing
them and
you know when fraver is like hey guys
what the [ __ ] is this and like yeah you
see it yeah we've been seeing these
things
and there's no upside for somebody like
that a very well respected you know
aviator uh with great experience
there's no upside for these guys to come
forward right in fact there's there's
pressure to not
because it's not necessarily good for
your career right right to come in and
say i think i saw ufo right
what do you think is going on uh
i know we've talked about that before i
i'm not you know
you're trying to get the right answer
out of you keep asking until you forget
what you said before
yeah i know right you forgot about the
damn bed i shouldn't open my mouth
[Laughter]
i know people will go back to that
though they would have called me out if
trump comes back and runs they would say
oh
you owe him a thousand bucks can't wait
to get that [ __ ] screaming eagle in
here that i'm gonna buy
you know i'm gonna put i'll buy it for
you with the money and i'll put a little
plaque on there to say where it came
from
i've got one i i gave a speech one time
up
for a veteran's day event and they uh
it was very kind they gave me this big
eagle i keep it in my office now it's
fantastic
i keep in the background when i do news
segments from my office and it's it's
like
perched over my shoulder you got to have
one in here
uh anyway it i you know i i don't know i
you think about it yeah i do in the
terms of and and like i said with black
files to classify coming up i just got
another plug-in
we uh we're going to do an episode
what's on the discovery channel isn't it
it is on discovery channel and you know
what you can see the entire first season
on discovery plus
[Music]
so i i i think it's it's foolish
to discount these things because i
there's so much we don't know
right so and the idea of of of thinking
that somehow we're the only you know
credible life forms out there i think is
is ridiculous so
i think it's a there's a high
possibility that
um that that there's
yes i i do think that but at the same
time then i also question
uh sort of the the way that
that's great if if some alien life force
with amazing
technology that we can't even fathom
right now comes to visit us
then what the hell are they doing are
they just sort of like watching us just
for the entertainment value
or so i'm always puzzled by that part
like you know the idea that you know i'd
i know they probably want to observe but
they won't don't want to interfere
it's probably if they're super advanced
they probably realize there's a process
that intelligent life goes through where
there's stages of their
evolutionary development in terms of use
of technology
understanding of each other mitigation
of war and conflict
and then ultimately entrance into the
galactic
federation
[Laughter]
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience